AS THE STARS HAD BACK-TO-BACK
WINS HEADING INTO MINNESOTA.
YOU
ZONE COVERAGE CATASTROPHE AT
OFFSIDE, TO THE STARS.
>> Daryl: DON'T HAHA COUNT THE
SERIES IN 20101 Daryl: TALKED A
LINE IN THE FROM BINNINGTON, LEW
SHOT AND BINNINGTON HAD IT TEAM
POWER PLALA BY RYAN BUT THE
REFEREE LOST SIGHT OF IT, BLEW
IT  THEY NEED. THE
CHANGE.
KLINGBERG HOPS ON, PAVELSKI,
AL
COMING, HE'S GOING TO IN THESE.
HE'S BEEN DYNAMITE IN  A FLOATE.
BINNINGTON COULD NEVERN A LITTL
THOMAS, ACROSS THE LINE, PUCK
LOOSE, SHORTHANDED
AGGRESSIVE MENTALLY AND
PHYSICALLY, YOU
FIRST SHORTY
FOURTH POWER PLAY FOR ST. LOUIS,
0 FOR 3, FIVE
>> Daryl: THEY'VE GIVEN UP FUNKY
GOALS LAST TWO OUTINGS, HAVE  G
MOMENT AND COVEREDED SAAD, B AF.
KLINGBERG WILL SKATE BEHIND THE.
LINDELL IN THE  BUCHNEVICH.
PARAYKO AT POINT.
BLOCKED FROM THE SLOT, PLA
CAPTAIN BOOKENDS THE SCORING